today I want to talk about how I
schedule my time so I'm waiting for my
computer to restart I got a new computer
and it's taking a long time to do
updates and a bunch of stuff and so I
hate wasting time I thought all right
we're gonna make an impromptu book video
I'm sitting on my trampoline right now
I'm gonna talk about how I schedule my
time and hopefully can help you guys cuz
i know you know it's one of the most
frequently asked questions that I get as
as an entrepreneur how do I manage my
time how do i balance things how do I
you know plan things out and so for me
I've talked about this before but I'm
really I really pay attention to chunk
in my days and I'm going to get into how
this relates to my book so most of my
mornings start the same i wake up at
seven-thirty i get to the gym at seven
forty-five i'm on the bike for half an
hour while I'm answering email on my
phone just kind of making sure that I my
head for the day and I only actually
respond the email if it's from my team
or from media or you know kind of
important contacts I'll look at
responding everybody for the rest of my
general inbox I respond to everything
from the day before so I didn't think
that you send me today I don't look at
today I only look at the day before
because the more you send out the more
comes back so I purposely don't want to
be super fast at sending out because
then I'm going to a lot of email back so
that'll take me half an hour I come back
up i'll work on my dance routine for
half an hour or 20 minutes pop in the
shower then we're nine o'clock i'll do
my gratitude stream on my live channel
sharing three things that I'm grateful
for with the live audience and they
share three things that's a lot of fun
then hop into a league of legends
business Q&A stream I play league and
answer your business and entrepreneur
question so that's a ton of fun too from
there I'll usually either do something
community related so it'll be half an
hour of a mastermind call or me being in
the comments YouTube comments for a bit
that's a consistent time slot
then I'll spend another half an hour
looking at the websites that I check on
daily could be my social media my
youtube comments there's about 20
websites that I load every day of things
I used to run my business or just find
interesting and so I look at those daily
the rest of the time slots the fill of
the day that may take me i'm not i'm not
looking at my calendar because my
computer is restarting but that may take
me to about eleven-thirty the rest of my
day then is chunked out depending on the
day so monday i'll spend time reviewing
all the videos for the channel reviewing
all the clips reviewing everything is
about to go out on the youtube channel
and given a seal of approval i'll spend
an hour and a half doing that then take
a 15-minute break them another hour and
a half doing that and then another hour
and a half doing my book stuff on
tuesday is my mentorship day and so i
have all the same kind of morning stuff
happening but then my 1130 awkward spot
i will be mentoring my team alex is
usually here then i'll have an hour and
a half with him and then i'll have
another hour half so i have i basically
have those four and a half hours for
heck are four and a half hours in in the
afternoon from 1130 on with a 15-minute
break in between on wednesday i'm
shooting video so today's wednesday when
i'm making this video so i spend the day
making video on Thursday is my public
facing day so it's meetings and calls
and hangouts and interviews and anything
where I have to put my presentation kind
of face on and then Friday is my CEO day
and I spend half that time work on tds
Toronto that salsa and half the time
working on on this business too then in
the evenings its a mix sometimes I have
meetings sometimes I have I might try to
that salsa three times a week between
auditing classes mentoring instructors
checking them out on our socials and
parties having meetings such three
nights a week it's a busy world do my
stuff daily how I do it is not the
specifics are not as important as the
method it's finding out what are the
major things that you want to do and
finding ways to check them so the thing
that I would take from my schedule is
there's some things I need to get done
every morning right I want to work
go I want to do my dance routine I want
to do my gratitude livestream my league
of legends live stream I want to check
on certain websites I want to check in
with my team like things that have to
get done daily and so I plan for that
and put it in the other stuff are things
that I want to get done weekly filming
videos doing meetings and I hate
switching between the two I would hate
like knowing that I had to rush to a
meeting after this so I'm rushing
through the videos and they're not as
good I would hate that and so I like
doing things that are multiple times per
week once per week and so a different
day for each habit really helps me and
this has really helped this is this has
had a big impact on my life a big impact
on how I run my company's it's really
helped me be insanely productive when
people look at my schedule I had to get
so much done well that's that's how I
chunk a lot of stuff together and I run
two businesses at the same time how this
relates to the book then is you know I
have one slot in my week for the book I
have an hour and a half slot on Monday
that I used to the book and so people
are sending me contracts or reviewing
agreements or you know whatever that's
the time we usually do it where things
start to change and what you have to
identify this in your life and your
business is sometimes you get hit with
with random opportunities or with things
that mess up your schedule right you
have the planned schedule and that you
know we make minor just into it as you
just and change and you want to grow and
learn new things you change the schedule
rounds fine it's a constant work in
progress but sometimes other things will
happen right and you may get notified by
Torme just strike you uh you know the
day off so for me I'm I'm getting close
to problem in the book the book is
coming out soon december six it's
finally actually here it's pretty I'm
pretty excited by it there's a whole
bunch of stuff that I have to do on
launch week there's so many interviews
my publisher basically asked me to book
off the entire week to be able to do
interviews and that messes up everything
else that I'm doing I have to find a way
to film videos in that time and do
everything else that I'm doing but when
you have these big opportunities you
find a way to make them work because
they're there one offs right i'm
launching my book once right if i do
another book then that will happen
whatever but you know if I get called in
to do the oprah winfrey show
that will happen that one time or if I
get called to goga you know consult the
president that'll happen that one time
and I'll make adjustments to my schedule
and that happens if that's happening to
you daily where you're constantly being
interrupted then I don't think you've
designed you know you're not getting
called by the president Oprah every day
so you know you're not setting
boundaries enough on the people in your
life and they're walking all over your
time and so I think that's where a lot
of people fall down so my schedule the
next several weeks is just insane
insanely packed with interviews and
podcasts and hang ads I'll manage it
I'll probably end up spending a lot of
extra time i'll probably end up working
into the mines to cover for everything
else that I'm doing our probably won't
spend as much time with my team as I
should be as I normally do but it's okay
because it's for our window of a couple
weeks as opposed to this is the new norm
right and if it becomes a new norm then
something else has to adjust if it's
happening consistently you need to take
a hard look at your calendar and make
some changes so that it supports your
life and what you want to accomplish so
that's how I run some of my schedule I
hope that makes sense if you guys have
questions let me know anything specific
I can let you guys know in the next next
week's videos but I want to get to the
comments I'm going to use the iPad
because a computer is still but nine
percent done on the updates it's crazy
it's a new computer anyway let me load
up the comments and see what you guys
have been saying on my last video first
up the bee song I saw your boca amazon
journeyman germany for pre-order too i
prefer to continue how you market your
book you can mix um hangouts though so
yeah great day it's in Germany it should
be everywhere now if it's not let me
know again and I'll keep harassing my
publisher I asked the question last week
what do you guys want to see what the
series which it wish we do what should
we continue with I don't know what I
would do for how we continue to market
the book my concern is it just gets
boring that's just going to be the same
thing but maybe not I guess I'll have to
see what happens to the excitement of
launch we can put it up I do like the
idea more more doing the book club and I
know a lot of you have commented on
liking that book club where once a week
we go through a different chapter I'm
there with you we can all discuss it and
if you have question
because I really want you to read the
book and apply it and understand it and
then have a group of people to connect
with to talk about it as well and they
may be on the last week we bring in I
help somebody out live or bringing a
guest or something I'm still playing
with it I'm glad you guys are liking it
thank you it's great feedback fanatics
media congrats would love to discuss it
with you on your show I believe we're in
contact fedex media has it as a fun
youtube channel helping people with
influencers helping to get influencers
to reach more people get their marketing
now and spread their message and so I
think we've already connected if we have
it let me know again and will definitely
set the time up looking forward to it
next up janina Evan where can I get the
audio book i check amazon an indigo i
couldn't find it a definite indigo
indigo is our barns and nobles in
cameras are here it's not ready for
release yet but it's in pre order and
the audio version is only on audible
right now usually you can't actually
pre-order audiobooks it's something that
the publisher they don't typically do
what they did it for us because if you
guys writing in and so if you go to
audible audible com it's an amazon
company you can you can pre-order the
audiobook so thank you for that next
nakuru congratulations again Evan
getting excited together with you it's
contagious I love it I think I think in
general for whatever your business is
you want to be excited to buy it right
I'm excited by my book it's been a long
process to get it out I'm excited by the
videos i do i'm excited you know why
most of the work that I'm doing and I
think it's important I think when you
are excited and it's genuine it's not
real but what is genuine it's not fake
right when it's genuine then other
people catch it Sam Walton said you need
to have passion it's like a fever it's
contagious other people will catch it
and it's a good lesson for you guys to
like you have that same love of energy
and excitement you may not express it
the same way you don't have to be no I'm
not really outgoing either but you don't
express the same way I do but if you
have energy and excitement other people
will notice it they'll gravitate towards
it they want to work with you they'll
get inspired by it as well
so I think it's important that you had
that passion for what you're doing
Janine is also writing are you having a
book launch party as well I mean I'm in
Toronto perhaps you can do a hangout
party for believe nation I don't know I
don't know what I'm gonna do initially I
was thinking about doing a live stream
hanging out on my channel in doing a
multi-hour launch event and have like my
family come on or parents or Nina or you
know friends colleagues people have been
involved in the book tell some
embarrassing stories talk about the book
a little bit but I'm so booked up with
other podcast interviews I don't know
that I'm gonna have the time which kind
of sucks I'm Paula gonna have a physical
party but I wanted to have an online
party I don't know I'm still thinking
about it but I know a lot of the time to
think about it it's just crazy I didn't
expect you know everything is so busy
and booked and then look at the you know
thursday that i usually do for my my
interviews and all that that's already
all packed all but the whole week is
nuts and then i just got an email
yesterday that tim ferriss wants to do
something in New York together because
he's launching a book as well his new
book they wanted to do a video or
something together I'm trying to figure
out can I get to New York and still do
all my interviews and stuff or do I have
to be here at my station be able to do
it it's just nuts and so I don't know do
you guys really want it do you want the
live hangout launch party I don't know
you might you might you might you might
get me to do it we'll see we'll see i
love i love it though i love the
excitement deanna another one yeah
congratulations you must be walking on
here on air I hear your excitement it's
infectious right it's the second con
when I ready I'm smiling over here
watching you and Nina open it open it be
excited about your business it'll be
infectious for other people I didn't
know you had an audiobook have to order
that too yeah audio book is up on on
this inaudible make sure you email in
your seat you get the bonuses for for
anything if you get the ebook the
audiobook the regular book just make
sure you email is a lot of people are
buying it but they don't email in the
receipt so you don't get the bonuses so
make sure you email it
I want you guys to get the bonuses staff
is saying I would love to host an event
a series of events let me know what you
have in mind Steph I can't guarantee but
I'm curious by what you have to what
your what's on your with what's going on
up here maybe we could do it Deanna I
would love to know how you came up with
the idea of the book the process
initially my agent wanted me to have a
book and I said I don't need a book I
don't want a book I don't want to write
a book I think books are you know i'd
rather make videos a time to write a
book I can make so many more videos and
it could reach a bigger impact have a
bigger audience he's convincing know
what if you had to write a book Oh would
it be and and we threw together
something and it wasn't really behind it
and he introduced me to a literary agent
who loved my message and I would I was
like you know what I guys I don't really
want to write this book as I as I
started thinking about it more came up i
was working on my one word and i would
talk about it because at the start when
I was telling these stories initially I
couldn't say what the book was about and
I was going through the process of
building my business around my one word
and interviewing other people who had
done it and I like this is a book this
is this is a book I want to write this
makes much more sense as a book than a
video and I want to write this book and
I pitched my agent and he hated it and I
pitched my literary agent and she didn't
like it either I said they thought it
was like it's a worksheet or something
it's a little workbook it's not a real
book like you guys this is huge this is
amazing this could easily be a book this
could be two books this could be a whole
series and they weren't getting it and
so I just had to sit on write it to show
them because I kept thinking it was just
a small little exercise we drew up the
first chapter and then pitched different
publishers and we got five of them
interested and they kind of been against
each other and we end up going with
penguin Random House that's my publisher
I basically had to sell my enthusiasm
and energy and show them you know but
maybe didn't do good enough job
explaining what i had in my mind you
know I think sometimes you can have this
vision this dream but you have to then
put into place and they weren't getting
it obviously from our first
conversations you know too smart people
that I respect and have a great time
working with didn't understand what I
was trying to
and so I just had to show them I was
just absolutely convinced that this was
not just a book but an amazing book like
a life-changing book I just had to start
writing it and show them my name it up
writing two books and we cut we cut an
entire book from my book we cut half the
book we cut six thousand words from the
book it's an entire book that we cut
because it was so much to say anyway so
that's how I came up with the idea i
love this out study group okay cool uh
please continue the gratitude videos I
do the gratitude videos are just not on
this channel I started the second
channel for live stuff and you can go to
the live channel you can see the
gratitude live streams there and some
interviews that I do there that don't
come to the main channel so yeah go
check that out every morning nine a.m.
eastern share through things you're
grateful for 10 minutes every morning
get that little injection of gratitude
and to move on with the day next up
David the superhero congratulations I've
been subscribed to you since I think
your first videos years ago 2008
according to youtube wow yeah I spent a
long time and i love how far you've
gotten just pre-ordered your book
through the book depository really
looking forward to it cool thank you for
that again send in your receipt so we
can send you the bonuses David yeah I've
come a long way since twenty two
thousand eight that's a long time I did
I didn't realize it's been eight years I
thought it was only like five or six but
I guess it's been eight thank you for
that loyalty man i really appreciate him
and for anybody who do you want to see
the work he wants to see the climb this
wasn't just handed to me right i did i
had no connections and i sucked on
camera it's just been a lot of work a
lot of hustle four thousand videos go
back on my channel look at the early
stuff and you'll see your you are
probably better like if your think about
getting to youtube you're probably
better right now than i was when i
started and so it's just mad hustle it's
just practice doing the work over eight
years to get here you do that you can
probably do it a lot faster than me next
up mostly day hiking hey Ivan congrats
on a new book thank you for that does
the bonus apply if you buy the kindle
version or you must buy the hard
yeah it applies to everything you know
the publisher has really weird
restrictions on stuff like we can't
bundle the audiobook with the e-book
with the hardcover book and you know
this restrictions on a whole bunch of
stuff but the bonus is I control so I
can do whatever I want which is amazing
so I just decided who ever buys anything
you get the bonus if you buy ten copies
of it you get the 10 bonus you know
twenty five to twenty five bullets all
that stuff just you just you have to
email me if you don't even will not mean
email one word again Carmical calm with
your receipt if you don't email then we
can't send you the bonus so just make
sure that gets there next up Luke
William will there be an audible version
already is broke it out thank you for
the support next up Davina
congratulations Evan thank you Davina I
ordered the audio version but now i want
the hardcover book as well i love it i
love how excited you are another comment
you got to get excited guys about what
you're doing looking forward to reading
/ listen to your book yeah I love both I
don't know I don't know how I would pick
I'm not an audiobook card but I would
listen to my own a book Abraham
definitely must get one is there going
to be autograph books the autograph
books I believe starts with the 10 book
package so if you buy ten bucks then we
can send you an autographed book and
again just like this limits on because
it's all from the publisher right at
this limits on what time what we can do
so if you're ever in Toronto I'm happy
to connect and sign your book but if you
want it kind of mail to you then you
need to buy the10 book package or
anything above includes an autograph
book and send in your receipt next up
Raquel what about something like Brendon
Burchard did with his first book but do
it according to your theme / book I love
it I don't know what Brendan did for his
first book so I would love to be
enlightened if you want to share some
wisdom there I'm open to modeling
success and seeing what we can do to get
better Kathleen congratulations Evan I
ordered my book in July will that copy
be autographed so again the autographed
for one book would not be autograph it's
10 plus but again if you're in Toronto
or if I'm traveling bring the book out
or for doing book signings or I don't
know I don't know what if we're going to
do a tour then what that might look like
then I'd love
be able to sign the books for you guys
the Mantis ok I was going to send you an
email when I got my book to order on my
amazon I feel like it was taking forever
but I can't wait to get my hardcover
book I feel like it's taking forever man
I feel you I feel your suffering pain
but it's coming december six what it's
going i'm gonna break my champlin i'm so
excited it's coming I think we're going
to end it there guys I gotta go on film
a video for trying to dance salsa and
Alex and give him some mentoring on that
too so thank you guys for watching thank
you for all the support I love to know
your thoughts on time management and if
you have any questions about my schedule
that I can answer for you next week also
if you have a question about my book the
book writing process anything I can help
you there leave it down the counts below
I will answer it and give you a shout
out in next week's video thank you guys
for all the support december six if you
have other resources ideas to share with
me again leave it leave it down there
i'll look at it next week and really
appreciate that I really believe in you
I hope you continue to believe in
yourself and whatever your one word is
much love I'll see you soon